[Music]
now a story that is a true change of
pace students at one japanese university
have created a form of synchronized
walking that has audiences riveted every
step of the way from yokohama lucy kraft
has the story
[Music]
it resembles a marching band without the
instruments or a kind of demented
military drill but the kinetic kookiness
is actually a japanese college tradition
known as shudan kodo group action
for over 50 years students at nippon
sports science university have been
busting moves
walking performances originated with
frustration over campus life said coach
jiro omi
students were fed up with long lines at
the cafeteria and even at the washroom
he said so they tried to come up with a
more efficient way of moving people
around
keeping time without a musical beat the
students managed to nail their signature
moves seeming to march headlong into
each other but weaving through unscathed
and repeating the trick in reverse
it wasn't always this easy
the hardest thing is getting everyone on
the same wavelength said senior kanto
mochizuki of course at first we always
ran right into each other
in rehearsal the 10-minute routines are
recorded every angle fine-tuned ad
nauseam the students have put in months
of intensive training to achieve this
level of precision tonight alone they've
walked the equivalent of six miles
coach me said anyone can learn to stride
and sink
all you have to do is walk he said even
grade school kids can master this
it's been called a masterpiece of
perfect coordination but showing off
isn't the point he said it's really
about teamwork and compassion
for cbs saturday morning lucy kraft
yokohama japan
it's mesmerizing it is but you know like
you said dana marching bands have been
doing that
for a long time with instruments but it
is very cool don't get me wrong very
cool and a few bust-a-moves not like not
like us walking to the walls before we
ever yeah
clearly i could not do that at three
o'clock in the morning
it's a different kind of scene that's
only you jeffrey todd
well